48 hours is shedding new light on the
misguided police investigation into the
murder of a young single mother in Ohio
in 2015 28 year-old Heather Bogle was
found dead in the trunk of her car just
a mile from her work her murder led to a
year-long investigation lead detective
Sean O'Connell pursued three innocent
people while the real killer hid in
plain sight CBS News chief investigative
correspondent Jim Axelrod reports 28
year-old Heather bogles car was found
just one mile from the Whirlpool plant
where she worked what they found inside
the trunk still haunts current Sandusky
County Sheriff
Chris Hilton they found a beautiful
young woman who had been savagely beaten
and murdered
Heather's fingernails had been cut down
to the cuticles possibly her murderers
attempt to destroy DNA and her hair had
been chopped
imagine taking like a pocketknife and
just going like this with it the hunt
for Heather's killer dragged on as the
lead detective Sean O'Connell focused on
three people omar satchel Kiana bore and
Kay Reid Jeffrey bore lived near where
Heather's body was found but O'Connell
ignored exculpatory evidence says the
sheriff he attempted to indict people
for murder that had absolutely nothing
to do with it
in a report to the prosecutor O'Connell
failed to mention that DNA evidence
excluded those three people an omission
that would help lead to O'Connell's
arrests for misleading a public official
and tampering with evidence do you feel
you Oh Oh Marcy satchel Kiana poor and
Kerri Jeffries an apology why would I
apologize I mean if you look at if you
look they didn't do it how do we know
that for sure they know it because they
found the real killer say sheriff Hilton
Heather's GPS coordinates from her phone
placed her in this trailer home 13
minutes after she was last seen leaving
work we find out later that day it
belongs to Daniel Meyers who was Daniel
Meyers we find out very quickly that
Danny Meyer's worked with Heather we
find out that he worked with her that
night we find out that he left
approximately the same time that morning
that's when we went we got something
slowly they began to piece together a
disturbing picture of a sexual predator
a man investigators say was focused on
control domination and humiliation after
his arrest the prosecutor says ten women
came forward and said Myers had raped
them and this woman Lori Ann Haley
believes Heather Bogle wasn't Daniel
Myers first murder victim you think your
sister is murdered
yes by Danny yes no question no question
and Jim Axelrod joins us now in studio
57 Jim why why didn't the original
detective have Myers on his suspect list
well that's what makes it such a rich
hour you really have two stories here
you have this brutal murder and you have
good police work that solve that but you
have some really bad police work to
start criminally bad police work
blinders but the question then becomes
was it incompetence was it ambition was
it racism we'll get into all of that and
do they think the police think this he
could be a serial killer well the thing
is well they're not ready to go that far
the killer ended up showing signs that
this wasn't his first rodeo he replaced
floorboards and carpet at
one of the murders at the murder scene
which led investigators to say well wait
a minute why how did he know to do that
obviously he had some experience or it
would be easy to assume that Jim thank
you